NATO the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization was set up in 1949 it began
as a defensive alliance between America
and Western European powers to guard
against the Soviet Union and its
communist satellites involved in a tense
rivalry with the West after the Second
World War it is now under pressure
particularly from Donald Trump in the
United States who thinks that his
European partners don't carry their fair
share of the burden and is wanting them
to spend a lot more money on defense and
there are various fundamental reasons
why Europe and America are not quite the
same soul mates as there used to be time
was a hundred years ago when almost all
of the immigrants in America or the
foreign-born population were from Europe
now only 10% are America's trade is
getting pulled off towards China and
China itself is the rising rival
superpower so America's attention is
increasingly drawn towards the Pacific
rather than across the Atlantic I think
it's important to say that NATO has been
extraordinarily successful it's often
called the most successful alliance in
history the average lifespan over the
past 500 years for a collective defense
alliance is just 15 years and NATO is 70
so it's it's a great success story
although it's true that Asia is rising
in particular and also other emerging
markets are becoming more important the
relationship between Europe and America
remains a terribly strong one 3 billion
dollars worth of trade every day lots of
shared interest shared values sometimes
wobbly at the edges but nevertheless
fundamentally a shared belief in
democracy which is something that can't
be said for for example China and Russia
and more authoritarian regimes that
America and its European partners
increasingly confront in order to stay
relevant for the future NATO needs to do
a number of things first of all it needs
to live up to the things that it's
already promised to do and back in 2014
NATO members promised that they would
aim to spend 2% of GDP on defense a lot
of countries are woefully short of that
so that's task number one the Europeans
in particular need to get much more
serious about plugging gaps in their own
defence capabilities but perhaps the
biggest task is the third one responding
to the rise of China a new world where
geopolitics is going to look very
different and NATO needs to really work
towards a new sort of partnership
between Europeans and Americans that can
really take into account a response to
China as a rival Challenger increasingly
in the future
[Music]
really the danger for NATO is that if it
doesn't respond vigorously enough
America in particular will go its own
way will get fed up will decide as
president Trump has already threatened
to do that it will just do its own thing
and walk away that would be very
worrying for many Americans but
particularly for the European allies if
NATO plays its cards right I think it
will continue to have a critical role in
the peace and prosperity for the coming
decades and that's the hope but it
should be very firmly setting its sights
on the future as it celebrates its 70th
birthday rather than indulging in
nostalgia for the past